China just scored yet another knockout
blow against the U.S Xi Jinping is now
scheduled to talk to Ukraine's president
zielinski to negotiate peace talks with
Russia see the U.S is usually the one to
negotiate peace talks but if China pulls
this off it would show to the world that
maybe America is not the person to go to
when you need help then maybe America's
days as the Undisputed superpower are
over Xi Jinping one of his main goals is
to to make China into a superpower and
so part of that is being involved in
security discussions and peace talks
around the world and it's not just with
Ukraine China successfully negotiated a
deal between Saudi Arabia and Iran to
re-establish diplomatic relations these
countries hated each other before China
did the same thing in Africa and it's
only gonna get worse